في البداية لم يكن لدي
أي هدف ، كنت موجودًا حرفيًا بالكاميرا
الخاصة بي والتقيت بسيارة إسعاف تُدعى مايك
جالاوي وطلبت منه
أن يخبرني بقصته ومن بين
أمور أخرى أخبرني أنه
منزعج  لأنه لم يعتقد أنه
كان لديه هو وزملاؤه ما يكفي من المساعدة الشخصية
وقال إنك تعلم أنني لا أعتقد أنني
الوحيد
الذي يشعر بهذه الطريقة بعد حوالي آه
شهر
تلقيت مكالمة هاتفية في إحدى الليالي من
مايك وهو  أخبرني
أن المسعف الأسطوري في نيويورك أم
أنتوني توني توماس
قد وافته المنية للتو من الطمع ،
وكان هناك حفل في منزل جنازة
في بروكلين وأراد معرفة
ما إذا كنت
على استعداد للحضور لتصوير هذا
الحفل لأن مايك و
أراد زملائه إعطاء
توني الوداع الذي يستحقه وقلت
إنه سيكون شرفًا
كل ليلة في الساعة السابعة صباحًا ، سيخرج العديد من
الممرضات
وأطباء مستشفى لينوكس هيل
والعديد من الأشخاص من مستشفى لينوكس هيل.
حي الجانب الشرقي العلوي wo  تعال
وأعبر عن تصفيق حار شديد الصادق
وشكرًا لهؤلاء العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية الأساسية في
هذه الليلة بالذات ، حيث
قامت سيارة بإيقاف أحد الشباب
فوق السيارة
بميكروفون ويبدأ في غناء أغنية
أمريكا الجميلة والرائعة
.  رأيت المرأة الموجودة في
صورة غلاف كتابي
واسمها إيريكا صادف أنها
من البرازيل عاشت في الولايات المتحدة
لفترة طويلة
إنها ممرضة مسافرة تركتها
شمال كارولينا للعمل مع
مرضى مطمئنين في لينوكس هيل
عندما نظرت إليها في المستشفى رأيتها تضع
يدها على
قلبها وهي تستمع إلى هذه الأغنية ورأيت
الدموع في عينيها وما أصابني
بعد أن التقطت هذه الصورة
هو أنني أشعر أن دموع إيريكا
هي دموعنا التي بكت من أجلها  كل واحد منا في
ذلك اليوم
عندما عدت إلى باريس هذه المدينة
التي أعرف جيدًا أن
ما أدهشني هو شيئان أحدهما
هو عالمية هذه
اللحظة ، المشاعر والعاطفة التي
كان يشعر بها الناس في باريس.  آخ
آخر ،
هذا النوع المماثل من التضامن ،
التقدير الذي
شعر به الناس للأشخاص الذين كانوا ينقذون
حياتهم ، والعاملين الأساسيين ،
كل هذا كان مشابهًا جدًا
لما رأيته في نيويورك ،
ما كان مختلفًا هو بعض
النقاط المرجعية المرئية لـ  وأود أن
أرى هؤلاء البارسيين الذين يمكنهم الآن
لأول مرة
في الأشهر الثلاثة حرفيًا القدوم
والجلوس في الخارج
وعدم عزلهم في المنزل ، وكان افتتاح اللوفر
في اليوم الأول
عاطفيًا بشكل لا يصدق بالنسبة لي ورأيت
زوجين شابين كانا يزوران
اللوفر من أوكرانيا قالوا
لي هل تمانع في جعلنا صورة
لنا لأن هذه اللحظة
تعني الكثير بالنسبة لنا وقلت بالطبع
وقاموا بلمس قناعهم بشفاه بعضهم البعض
بقبلة أمام الموناليزا و
اعتقدت أن هذا كان
رمزًا رائعًا لتلك اللحظة حيث قمت بالتقاط هذه
الصور خلال هذه الفترة من الوقت الذي
تطمح فيه وتحدثت إلى الناس
وشاركت قصصهم  لحسن الحظ
،
كانت الحاجة لدينا جميعًا في جميع أنحاء العالم
للتعرف على بعضنا البعض ،
وأعتقد بشدة أننا جميعًا
أعضاء في عائلتنا البشرية ،
كل شخص على هذه الأرض هو أخي
وأختي وهذا النوع من الحب لبعضنا البعض
و  الاعتراف بجمال
تنوعنا يمكننا المضي قدمًا
شكرًا لك